il faut d'urgence levé les brevets des
vaccins contre le coc vide
c'est ce que plaide dans un rapport
publié ce jeudi la coalition de angie
people ce maxi d'alliance dans laquelle
figurent notamment amnesty international
et oxfam et surtout une centaine de pays
comme l'inde ou l'afrique du sud
face à l'urgence de vacciner people se
vaccine alliances explique que les
compagnies pharmaceutiques en situation
de monopole vendre leurs vaccins à des
prix exorbitants pour réaliser des
profits records ong oxfam met en avant
les résultats financiers hors norme du
géant pfizer dévoilé le 28 juillet son
vaccin contre le coc ville lui a
rapporté 11,3 milliards de dollars entre
janvier et juin 2021 lever les brevets
permettrait de casser les prix des
vaccins pour qu'ils puissent être
équitablement partagé avec les pays
pauvres
oxfam dénonce une situation inverse big
pharma préféré assurer la livraison de
ses juteux contrats avec les pays
développés qui lui assure des milliards
d'euros de revenus
la situation de quasi monopole des
grands acteurs pharmaceutiques leur
permet de gonfler les prix de vente des
vaccins
selon les calculs de people se vaccine
une dose de vaccin arn messagers
coutterand production de 1,18 dollar la
dose pour le kaiser à 2,85 dollars pour
le moderna ils sont revendus jusqu'à 20
fois leur prix ce coût a certes était
calculée sans compter la recherche et la
distribution mais tout de même en france
le surcoût pour les contribuables et de
4,6 milliards d'euros pour la belgique
le surcoût et 2 796 millions d'euros et
pour l'europe
en tout 31 milliards un gouffre pire le
vaccin de pfizer a même augmenté passant
d'un prix de vente de 12 euros à 15,5
euros pour atteindre 20 euros pour les
commandes de l'union européenne en 2022
big pharma profite bien de la pandémie
pour engranger des milliards
les bons élèves johnson and johnson et
astrazeneca se sont engagés à vendre
leurs vaccins à prix coûtant à tous les
pays
le temps de la pandémie mais pas modern
and his father ils ne vendent à prix
coûtant aux réduits qu'au pays pauvres
ou intermédiaire quel humanisme
mais bien entendu qui est lésé par cette
scandaleuse politique du chiffre les
pays en développement car seuls 14 % de
la population mondiale est vacciné -2 2%
en afrique contre près de 50 % en
grande-bretagne et en france le manque
d'équité flagrant malgré le dispositif
kovacs mises en place pour assurer une
couverture vaccinale
égalitaire dans le monde entier ces
négociations se sont révélées
particulièrement inefficace le 10 juin
le parlement européen a adopté une
résolution en vue de négocier une
évolution des accords de propriété
intellectuelle côté politique le
président américain joe biden s'est
prononcée pour la levée des brevets le 5
mai dernier
emmanuel macron le 10 juin après avoir
longuement hésité je suis tout à fait
favorable à ce qu'il y ait en effet
cette ouverture de la propriété
intellectuelle vous m'avez entendu le
dire il ya un an quand nous avons lancé
l'initiative acta ce qui rend difficile
l'accès au vaccin
c'est ce sera un moment donné le prix et
l'accès à la propriété intellectuelle
c'est aujourd'hui le transfert de
technologie et la capacité à produire
car il ne suffit pas de lever les
brevets il faut aussi assurer le
transfert de technologie des
laboratoires qui elle reste secrète
oxfam a identifié au moins cent quarante
quatre sites de production dans plus de
35 pays qui pourraient contribuer à la
fabrication locale des vaccins anti
qu'ovide tout reste donc à inventer pour
un accès égalitaire aux vaccins et pour
que certaines compagnies pharmaceutiques
cesse de s'engraisser sans limite sur le
dos des contribuables
l'inde ou l'afrique du sud ont demandé
la levée des brevets dès octobre 2020
qu'il est long et difficile de juguler
l'appétit de big pharma pour assurer le
bien commun